je
il a ressenti le besoin de comptanoo
leur groupe à nous de travailler
ensemble parce que le cinéma l'estran et
c'est un travail d'équipé et naples and
real plein de coeurs d'horizons très
différents si c'est ça des chouettes en
tout cas dans cet espace passé que la
plains d'esthétique y croise des gens
qui fait des foules de gens de sortir
des films d'auteur et nous aimeraient
que déjà un péloquin mais que devient
vraiment l'espace des auteurs et des
lecteurs
c'est un atelier de lecture de scénario
du coup on est des auteurs réalisateurs
qui se réunissent ici on fait ça
plusieurs fois par an quand on écrit on
est seul avec notre scénario est là
c'est pour reprendre un peu de recul
avoir des avis le tout bienveillant et
là c'est génial parce qu'on peut se
réunir à plusieurs auteurs tous se faire
des échanges très différent et ça a
permis d'enrichir et on ressort avec des
notes on évolue on en reparle
et tout le monde a une sensibilité
différente
[Musique]
globules rouges
on a notamment des master class qui ont
pour but aussi donner encore plus une
vision d'ensemble à nos auteurs
réalisateurs souvent comme des
formations sur la relation aux monteurs
la relation à l'assistant real la
relation compositeur de musique pour
aussi bas qu on ait un maximum d'armes
avant d'arriver sur nos tournage et être
le plus équipé possible pour pépé est
mon bébé ma travaille pour l'entreprise
coloniale des sucreries de bourbon donne
l'ont fait à des six documentaires océan
indien
alors c'est une résidence qui a lieu
depuis maintenant 2016 et donc je
l'animent avec mohamed saïd au grain
chaque année nous lançons dans les cinq
pays de l'océan indien madagascar
comores la la la réunion
maintenant mayotte et puis maurice nous
lançons des ateliers porté par chaque
pays ensuite nous nous faisons une
semaine de regroupement où nous faisons
rencontré aux auteurs